hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 american science fiction and action
movie called ken
the movie begins in an abandoned and
half destroyed factory where it seems
like a battle is happening inside
a few moments later an explosion goes
off causing a huge hole in the walls
the scene moves to a young boy named
elijah who is just suspended from school
after causing some trouble
since his father can't make it to the
school a teacher offers to drive him
home
soon after he visits a grave and then
rides his bike around the factory to
collect some old junk
he eventually arrives at the abandoned
factory shown in the beginning of the
movie and sneaks into the place
while exploring he is very shocked when
he discovers several dead bodies
equipped with super-advanced guns and
modern suits eli attempts to touch the
gun and accidentally activates it with
his thumb but he doesn't realize that
the dead body near the gun begins to
move which frightened eli and he
immediately escapes from the factory and
rides home
eli's father hal silinski returns home
and is very disappointed with his boy's
attitude while helping his father eli
claims that he attacked his schoolmate
because he was speaking ill of his
mother which ended up in a suspension
for him
hal understands that and gives word of
advice to his son telling that he acts
hard towards him because the world is
hard
that evening eli's brother jimmy finally
comes home after spending six years of
his life in prison
he explores the house and accidentally
spots eli's dirty shoes
he promises his brother that he will
give him a new pair
the family then have an awkward intense
dinner where jimmy asks his father
whether he can get a job on the site but
how refuses to help him as he is an
ex-con
disappointed jimmy walks out from the
dinner and heads over to his former
employer's house to finish old business
upon arrival it is revealed that jimmy
owes the drug dealer taylor batik 60
grand and he informs them that he
doesn't have the money with him now
taylor is unhappy with the information
and threatens him that he and the gang
will go after his family
jimmy talks to his dad about the debt
and attempts to borrow money from him
but hal is not interested in that he
then mentions a safe that is kept in
hal's office planning to steal the money
from there
hal furiously forbids him from doing so
and kicks him out of the house
immediately
before he leaves jimmy is upset that his
father has erased every trace of him in
the house revealing that eli is actually
a replacement son
meanwhile eli quietly returns to the
abandoned factory where finds the alien
gun and decides to take it with him
because it looks cool the next day hal
becomes enraged when he finds out that
his son is stealing some junk to gain
some money he then takes eli with him to
the construction site where he works but
hal notices something odd and tells his
son to wait in the car
he walks to the office where he
confronts jimmy taylor and his gang are
attempting to break into the safe
jimmy warns his dad not to intervene but
he insists ordering them to put the
money back
taylor then shoots hal but jimmy
immediately grabs the gun and fires
taylor's henchmen including his brother
dutch who is shot in the neck
hal dies in the process and jimmy uses
this opportunity to grab the money and
rushes to the car
he drives the car away in panic while
lying to eli saying that their dad calls
him to pick him off since he is busy
they return home to take everything
necessary and jimmy decides to take eli
with him to flee to lake tahoe
not long after the gangsters arrive at
hal's house but find nobody
taylor holds a funeral for his brother
and orders all his men to hunt jimmy on
the other side two soldiers who talk in
foreign language arrive at the abandoned
factory to retrieve the alien gun but
couldn't find it as it was taken by eli
after driving far they decide to stay
overnight in a motel where eli discovers
that the alien gun has three unique
attacking types
jimmy also fulfills his promise to get
his brother a new pair of shoes
the next morning eli sneaks away to the
car and attempts to call his dad but no
one answers thus he sends a voicemail to
him revealing his final destination to
taylor who turns out still holding hal's
phone
afterward they continue their journey to
the west and jimmy brings his brother to
a strip club where he shows him how to
flirt with a dancer millie
she accepts jimmy's invitation to get
drunk with him and acts friendly towards
him and eli after that
milly goes back to work and the brothers
continue drinking
jimmy always dodges when being asked
about him and his dad
at some point he gets drunk and tries to
go on stage to dance with millie the
club owner lee and the bouncers try to
stop him but jimmy keeps acting cocky
and ends up getting beaten up repeatedly
eli runs to grab his alien gun and
threatens the bouncers with it a falling
pool cue startles him and he fires the
weapon at the table destroying it into
pieces
millie jimmy and eli then escape from
the club and drive away
they pull over for a while and jimmy
tries to activate the gun but it closes
up
eli then tries to demonstrate the gun's
capability by firing it towards
haystacks
soon after jimmy realizes that he left a
bag full of money in the club
the tree then stays at a motel where
millie asks about jimmy's scar in the
hand
he claims that he got it from his
original parents
later that night millie proposes a plan
to get the money back from lee but she
wants a cut of the money if the heist is
successful to which he agrees
the three drive to a cow farm and the
brothers sneak into the shelter where
they confront lee and his friends
jimmy threatens to shoot them with the
alien gun if they don't comply while
ordering lee to return the money after
receiving the money back the two escape
while being chased by the men
lucky for them they still managed to
flee after eli launches a huge blast at
a car
meanwhile the soldiers arrive at the
club releasing a super advanced device
that allows them to see what was
happening there
they also managed to identify elijah
with a gun
the next day they stop for a moment at
the casino and book a hotel room for a
night
there jimmy feels uneasy and feels
guilty for what he had done
to relieve the stress he decides to
waste the money at the casino while
eating eli sees the news on the tv
learning that his dad has been killed
and the police suspect the brothers as
the culprit he rushes to the casino and
confronts jimmy
realizing that they may be in trouble
they try to escape but get arrested by
the local officers on the other side
taylor is informed about jimmy's arrest
and he immediately heads over to the
police station
back to jimmy he finally tells the truth
about him and taylor stealing money from
their father's safe and how hell ended
up dead he apologizes to eli who seems
very upset with his brother
a few moments later taylor and the gang
arrive at the police station where they
ruthlessly eliminate the police one by
one
one of the officers enters the room
where eli stays
the boy begs him to reveal the location
of his gun then the officer reluctantly
gives the key to him and orders him to
go to the evidence room
long story short taylor finds jimmy and
drags him out of his custody he doesn't
want to kill jimmy yet as he waits for
eli to show up and watch his brother
getting killed
eli arrives with his gun and directly
fires it towards one of the men
the gunfights ensue but it is a
one-sided fight as eli manages to
eliminate each gangster just with one
shot
at some point he switches the gun style
and fires it releasing a huge blast that
destroys the whole quarter
meanwhile the fbi arrives and surround
the place
jimmy realizes that there is no way out
now and orders eli to surrender he
apologizes to his brother but doesn't
expect him to forgive him either just
after they kneel down taylor suddenly
comes out of nowhere pointing his gun at
jimmy however just before taylor pulls
the trigger the soldiers charge towards
the police station with their superbikes
the police attempt to take them down by
shooting them continuously but to no
avail as their helmets and suits are
bulletproof
one of them throws a grenade which
freezes everyone inside the room except
elijah
taylor has fired the gun and the bullet
is heading towards jimmy they approach
eli who is freaked out and pointing his
gun at them they then reveal themselves
and the man claims that eli is one of
them that's why he is able to activate
and operate the alien weapon
he also shows the same scars in his hand
which makes eli trust him and decides to
hand over the weapon to him
after that the woman opens up a portal
to another dimension
the man forbids eli to go with them as
their world is in a war
before they leave the woman deflects the
bullet towards taylor's head
time goes back to normal and the bullet
eventually hits taylor at the same time
swat blows up the door and arrests the
brothers jimmy is taken to custody again
and agent morgan hunter talks to eli but
he refuses to reveal the weapon's
whereabouts
she then walks away while saying that
they are not done
millie eventually arrives for eli and as
he sees her his hand starts to glow
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching